mysterio and spider-man's rooftop chat  involved recreating the prague skyline  digitally when peter meets fury there  are more digital effects than you think  the blowdart fury's gun and the hologram  device were all digital and the room  behind fury was digital as well the  background may be cgi but tom holland  actually ran across these poles he also  did this pole vault stunt the water  during this scene was freezing cold and  they had to do a second take after the  sfx guy messed up on the first one the  sfx guy go sorry  the washington monument rescue scene  involved a lot of green screen and a lot  of impressive stunts